Hallo, guten Tag, Omer Demir ist mein Name. Ich bin hier als Assistenzarzt tätig und möchte
mit Ihnen das Anamnese-Gespräch führen. Bevor wir anfangen benötige ich kurz Ihre
persönlichen Daten. Sind Sie damit einverstanden? Ja, die brauchen Sie ja, ist ja ganz klar, logisch.
Wie heißen Sie bitte? Ich heiße Peter Lüders. Könnten Sie mir bitte Ihren
Vor- und Nachnamen langsam und deutlich buchstabieren? Ja, der Vorname ist Peter, P-E-T-E-R,
ein Männername, ne? Und Lüders, L-Ü, also U umlaut, D-E-R-S, Lüders. E wie Emil, oder? Am Ende,
also ja nach dem D, E-R-S, genau. Okay, ja verstanden. Herr Lüders, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 69. Wann genau sind Sie geboren? Am 23. März 57. Wie groß sind Sie? 179. Und wie viel
wiegen Sie zurzeit? Ich wiege nur noch 74 Kilo. Okay, vielen Dank für die Angaben. Was kann ich
für Sie tun? Was führt Sie heute zu uns, Herr Lüders? Ja, also mein Hausarzt schickt mich,
ne? Der hat gesagt, ja gehen Sie doch mal in die Klinik, das gefällt mir nicht. Und zwar,
ja, habe ich heute morgen bei dem angerufen und habe Bescheid gesagt. Ich habe eigentlich
schon jetzt seit zwei Wochen habe ich immer so Bauchschmerzen hier so im Oberbauch. Und ja,
eigentlich bin ich auch schon eine ganze Weile, merke ich, dass ich so ein bisschen schlapp bin.
Ich habe dann gedacht, naja gut, in meinem Alter und Rentner und man arbeitet nicht mehr so viel.
Da wird man so ein bisschen träge und müde. Aber irgendwie ist es schon ein bisschen doller
geworden. Und ja, das Essen schmeckt mir nicht so richtig gut. Und ich habe mich dann auch in
den letzten Tagen, musste ich mich zweimal übergeben. Und ja, und in meiner Verdauung,
das stimmt irgendwie auch irgendwas nicht. Ich habe irgendwie mal Verstopfungen und dann habe
ich wieder ganz dollen Durchfall und dann bin ich wieder verstopft. Und jetzt heute Morgen,
das hat mir dann, ja deswegen habe ich dann beim Hausarzt angerufen. Da sah das,
also das, was im Klo war, also der Stuhlgang, das sah ganz schwarz aus. Das war richtig
gespenstisch. Ja, okay. Heute Morgen haben Sie diese schwarzen Stuhl bemerkt. Ja,
ja, ja. Und dann habe ich halt gleich bei meinem Hausarzt angerufen. Er hat dann gesagt,
ja, kommen Sie mal vorbei. Und dann hat er mich aber gleich hierher geschickt.
Ja, okay, verstanden. Sind diese Beschwerden plösslich oder eher langsam aufgetreten?
Ja, das geht natürlich schon eine ganze Weile, dass ich immer mal so Bauchschmerzen
habe und ja, und auch dieses mit dem, mit dem, dass ich mal verstopft bin und dann mal
Durchfall habe, das ist natürlich auch nicht von heute auf morgen gekommen. Das ist schon seit
paar Wochen so oder eigentlich vielleicht schon sogar ein paar Monate, wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Ja, gab es, wie sagt das Erbrochene aus? Haben Sie etwas Auffälliges bemerkt? Sie
haben gesagt, Sie haben zweimal erbrochen haben. Ja, aber das sah eigentlich, ja, so aus wie
das Essen, was man halt gegessen hat, ne? Essen, Resten. Ja, genau.
Ist Ihnen einen konkreten Auslöser für diese Beschwerden aufgefallen? Zum Beispiel eine
Infektion oder eine Verletzung oder sowas? Nee, das fing ja so langsam an und ich
wüsste jetzt nicht, Infektion, also wenn ich jetzt was Gammeliges gegessen hätte, dann
wäre das ja im nächsten Augenblick wieder gut, aber das hört ja gar nicht auf.
Was essen Sie, wenn Sie Linderung bekommen? Um Linderung zu bekommen? Ja, also dann mach
ich mir halt manchmal, mache ich mir halt Zwiebap und Tee, wenn ich Bauchschmerzen
habe oder meine Frau kocht mir auch mal so einen Haferbrei und dann esse ich auch
mal eine Banane oder irgendwie sowas, ja, also was mir zurzeit überhaupt nicht
schmeckt und was ich auch nicht gut riechen kann, wenn das irgendjemand so Fleisch auf
dem Grill hat oder so, also Fleisch mag ich eigentlich zurzeit gar nicht essen.
Ich esse ganz viel Gemüse und Eier esse ich auch wohl ganz gerne mal, aber Fleisch mag ich nicht.
Außer vielleicht diese Tee, Haferbrei, Banane bringt Ihnen Linderung?
Ja, dann habe ich das Gefühl, dass es mir nicht so schlecht ist, ne?
Wie viele mal müssen Sie zur Toilette gehen, ich meine beim Stuhl, mit Stuhl?
Ja, das kommt halt total drauf an. Manche Tage, manchmal vier Tage überhaupt nicht
und dann habe ich Tage, wo ich dann so ganz dünnflüssigen Stuhl habe und dann muss ich
viermal, fünfmal am Tag laufen, ne? Dann kommt aber immer nur so ein bisschen, ne?
Ja. Okay. Aber haben Sie zum ersten Mal heute Morgen diese schwarzen Stuhl bemerkt, oder?
Ja, dass das so schwarz ist, habe ich noch nie gesehen.
Ja, okay. Wie stark sind Ihre Bauchschmerzen auf einer Skala von 0 bis 10? 0 bedeutet keine
Schmerzen, 10 bedeutet sehr starke Schmerzen.
So schlimm sind die nicht. Das blöde ist halt, dass die überhaupt nicht weggehen,
dass das so gar nicht besser wird. Also ich würde, also vielleicht so kurz unter der Mitte,
so 4 bis 5 so.
Ja, okay. Wie beschreiben Sie diese Schmerzen? Sind sie stechend, drückend?
Nein, es drückt richtig, ja.
Strahlen die Schmerzen irgendwo aus, zum Beispiel in den Rücken oder in den unteren Bauch?
Ich würde sagen nicht. Eigentlich ist das hier so oben im Bauch, so oberhalb vom Bauchnabel,
würde ich sagen. Und ja, so ein bisschen um den Bauchnabel rum noch vielleicht.
Ja, okay. Setzen die Schmerzen erstmal auf oder hatten Sie früher solche Schmerzen?
Ja, also den Magen hat man sich natürlich in seinem Leben schon mal irgendwann verdorben,
ja. Aber jetzt so dieses, diese drückenden Schmerzen, würde ich sagen, nee, das kenne
ich nicht.
Seit wann genau haben Sie diese Verstopfung und Durchfall, diese wechselnde Stuhlgewohnheiten?
Ja, ich würde sagen, das ist schon mehrere Monate eigentlich. Ja, das ist bestimmt
schon ein halbes Jahr oder so.
Waren Sie deswegen bei einem anderen Arzt?
Ja, ich habe das meinem Hausarzt wohl mal gesagt, aber dann hat er halt gesagt, ja,
dann nehmen Sie halt mal so Flohsamen oder Leinsamen, damit die Verdauung wieder in
Gang kommt.
Wurde bei Ihnen eine Diagnose festgestellt?
Nee, also nur die bekannten Sachen, was weiß ich, ich habe halt ein Diabetes,
und mein Blutdruck ist ein bisschen hoch, aber sonst, nee, wegen dem Bauch wurde jetzt
nichts diagnostiziert.
Okay, haben Sie oder hatten Sie Fieber?
Boah, ich habe mich nicht gemessen, aber ich habe mich eigentlich auch nicht fiebrig
gefühlt, muss ich sagen.
Spüren Sie, dass Ihr Herz nicht regelmäßig schlägt oder stolpert oder fühlen Sie
Herzrasen?
Nee, das habe ich eigentlich nicht. Also ich würde sagen, das Herz, am Herzen habe
ich nichts, ich habe es am Bauch.
Ja, okay, ja, verstanden. Spüren Sie Atem noch?
Nee, nee.
Ist Ihnen irgendwelche Hautveränderungen aufgefallen, zum Beispiel Gelbsucht oder
Gelbhautverfärbung oder Blasen im Haut oder sowas?
Ja, ich bin auch nicht so viel in der Sonne, ein bisschen blass bin ich nach dem Winter
vielleicht, aber gelb oder so, würde ich sagen, ist nichts.
Ist Ihnen ein Blasen in Ihrem Haut aufgefallen?
Ich habe das nicht verstanden.
Ja, aber nach dem Winter sieht man ja eh, also ich bin ja auch nicht in Urlaub gefahren
oder so, da sieht man ja immer ein bisschen blass aus.
Das ist gewöhnlich für Sie, oder?
Ja.
Okay.
Ja, okay.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlasten?
Naja, in meinem Alter, das wissen Sie ja, da ist das schon mal so, da muss
man schon manchmal auf die Toilette in der Nacht, ja.
Also zweimal gehe ich eigentlich schon jede Nacht, ne?
Zweimal?
Okay.
Haben Sie einen Arzt aufgesucht für diese?
Ja, also wir haben mal geguckt nach der Prostata, aber da war nichts auffälliges.
Ja, alles in Ordnung.
Die ist ein bisschen vergrößert, aber nichts Spannendes.
Okay, Sie haben schon erzählt, dass Ihr Appetit derzeit nicht gut ist, oder?
Ne, mir schmeckt es überhaupt nicht, ja.
Und das eigentlich jetzt schon eine ganze Weile, muss ich sagen.
Ja, ist Ihr Gewicht, hat sich Ihr Gewicht in letzter Zeit mehr oder weniger verändert?
Ja, ich habe deutlich abgenommen.
Wie viel Kilo und innerhalb von wie vielen Monats oder Wochen?
Ja, also im halben Jahr fast 10 Kilo.
Ich habe immer 84 Kilo gewogen und jetzt wiege ich nur noch 74, ja.
Okay, 10 Kilo innerhalb von ungefähr?
Halben Jahr.
Ja, okay.
Leiden Sie unter Nachtschweiß oder mehr Schütterpros?
Ne, also Nachtschweiß, ich schwitze, also nachts wache ich nur auf, weil ich
eben auf die Toilette muss, ne?
Ja.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Einschlafen?
Ne, beim Einschlafen eigentlich nicht.
Ich wachte nur halt zwischendurch auf und deswegen schlafe ich so.
Das ist insgesamt ein bisschen schlecht.
Okay, Herr Lüders, ich möchte jetzt über Ihre Vorgestellungen etwas fragen.
Sie haben schon kurz erwähnt, dass Sie Diabetes, Blutzucker und Bluthochdruck
haben.
Ja.
Haben Sie noch weitere Vorerkrankungen?
Ja, also ich habe noch Arthrose in den Knien und in den Hüften, also deswegen bin ich
auch nicht mehr so viel draußen unterwegs.
Hab halt viel gearbeitet in meinem Leben, ja.
Welche Seite haben Sie diese Knie?
Beide Knie, beide Hüften, ja, da habe ich überall Schmerzen.
Seit wann haben Sie die?
Ach, das fängt ja auch so langsam an.
Wissen Sie, irgendwann merkt man, dass man nicht mehr sich gut bewegen kann.
Ich würde sagen, das ist bestimmt jetzt schon fast zehn Jahre.
Okay.
Seit wann haben Sie Bluthochdruck?
Ja, das hat man eigentlich erst so vor fünf Jahren festgestellt.
Okay.
Welcher Tipp von Zuckerkrankheit haben Sie, wissen Sie?
Ja, also diesen Alterszucker, das hat man erst vor 15 Jahren.
Wann wurde das bei Ihnen festgestellt?
Das ist 15 Jahre her.
Also ich war da, da war ich 54, genau.
Noch weitere Vorerkrankungen?
Nee, das ist auch schon eigentlich genug, würde ich sagen.
Was nehmen Sie als Medikamenten regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf ein?
Ja, ich habe halt nicht Formin für diese Zuckerkrankheit.
In welcher Dosierung und wie oft?
800 und die nehme ich morgens ein zurzeit.
Und das klappt eigentlich damit so ganz gut.
Ist Ihr Brustzucker gut eingestellt, oder?
Ja, damit ist es eigentlich gut eingestellt.
Also das kontrolliert der Hausarzt eigentlich auch in größeren Abständen.
Aber da merke ich eigentlich jetzt keine Probleme mehr.
Okay.
Noch weitere Medikamente?
Ja, wenn ich mal Schmerzen habe, dann nehme ich mal Ibuprofen ein, ja.
Welche Dosierung?
Ja, das sind 600er, glaube ich, ja.
Aber wie gesagt, wenn ich mal Kopfschmerzen habe oder wenn die Bauchschmerzen zu schlimm sind oder so,
dann nehme ich das wohl mal.
Okay.
Noch weitere Medikamente gegen zum Beispiel Bluthochdruck?
Ja, da haben wir mal was probiert und das ist mir aber nicht bekommen.
Dann haben wir das wieder abgesetzt.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wie das hieß.
Aber das war jedenfalls, ist mir davon schlecht gegangen und dann habe ich das nicht mehr genommen.
Derseits nehmen Sie keine Medikamente?
Nee, ist nämlich nichts dagegen, nee.
Okay.
Ja, so riesig hoch ist der, glaube ich auch nicht.
Ja, okay.
Wegen Gelenkprobleme bekommen Sie etwas?
Wegen was?
Knieverschleiß und Hüftgelenkverschleiß.
Ach so, nee, Medikamente nehme ich da nicht.
Also ja, wie gesagt, wenn die Schmerzen mal zu doll sind, wenn ich dann merke,
ich kann mich gar nicht bewegen oder ich kann auch nachts nicht schlafen,
weil ich da Knieschmerzen habe oder so, dann nehme ich mal eine Ibuprofen,
aber nicht so oft.
Wurde bei Ihnen bisher eine Operation durchgeführt?
Als Kind habe ich mal die Mandeln rausbekommen, aber sonst habe ich nichts.
Sonst bin ich noch nie operiert worden.
War die OP-Komplikation so?
Ja, ist ja schon lange her und das ist ja auch nur eine kleine Geschichte bei Kindern.
Ja, okay.
Sind bei Ihnen irgendwelche Allergien bekannt, Herr Lüders?
Allergien?
Ja, ich darf ein Schmerzmittel nicht nehmen.
Novalgien darf ich nicht nehmen.
Okay, was bekommen Sie, wenn Sie...
Da kriege ich Hautausschlag, ja.
Und das ist nicht so.
Und dann hat man auch mal festgestellt, dass ich Jod nicht vertragen kann.
Jod.
Nicht Joghurt, nein Jod.
Was bekommen Sie, wenn Sie...
Ja, da habe ich tatsächlich so Luftnot bekommen.
Wie haben Sie diese Unvertretigkeit bemerkt, Jod-Unvertretigkeit?
Ja, das fing, glaube ich, an mit einer äußerlichen Anwendung, dass ich da erst mal Hautausschlag bekommen habe.
Und dann habe ich mal irgendwann jodhaltiges Medikament bekommen und da war das dann ganz schlecht.
Okay, verstanden.
Rauchen Sie, Herr Lüders?
Ja, aber nicht mehr doll.
Ich rauche jetzt nur noch 10 Zigaretten am Tag.
Das ist nicht mehr so viel.
Seit wann rauchen Sie 10 Zigaretten täglich?
Ja, seit ich im Ruhestand bin, so ungefähr, ja, so ungefähr, ja, knapp 10 Jahre.
Okay.
Hatten Sie früher mehr als 10 Zigaretten geraucht?
Ja, früher habe ich ein Päckchen am Tag geraucht.
Da habe ich schon 20 am Tag geraucht.
Wie lange?
Viele Jahre.
Bestimmt 30 Jahre.
Okay.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Eigentlich trinke ich so jeden Abend zwei Flaschen Bier und eigentlich auch noch mal so einen Schnaps.
Aber zurzeit schmeckt mir der Schnaps nicht, ehrlich gesagt.
Und das Bier, ja, das ist mir jetzt auch nicht mehr so gut bekommen.
Schnaps trinken Sie nicht jeden Tag?
Ja, also habe ich früher eigentlich regelmäßig getrunken,
aber jetzt mit den Bauchschmerzen habe ich das ein bisschen weniger.
Manchmal habe ich gedacht, ja, das hilft vielleicht so gegen die Schmerzen,
so ein kleiner Schnaps hinterher, aber dem war dann doch nicht so gut.
Bitte nehmen Sie die nächste Frage nicht persönlich, das ist eine Routinefrage.
Konsumieren Sie Drogen?
Drogen?
Nein, nein, also außer Schnaps und Bier trinke ich, nehme ich keine Drogen.
Okay.
Leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Nein, nein, nein, meine Eltern dürfen noch.
Woran ist Ihr Vater gestorben, wenn ich fragen darf?
Ja, er hatte Krebs und zwar hatte er Krebs im Darm.
Ihr Mutter?
Er ist noch nicht alt geworden.
Ja, verstanden.
Und dann meine Mutter war sehr schwer depressiv und die hat sich dann,
weil sie mit dem Alleinsein, als mein Vater dann verstorben ist,
hat sie sich das Leben genommen, also das war sehr furchtbar, ja.
Ja, das tut mir sehr leid, das sollte für Sie sehr berastend sein.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, Geschwister hatte ich nicht, war Einzelkind.
Okay, sind Sie verheiratet, Herr Lüders?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, aber die sind natürlich schon groß, die sind ja auch aus dem Haus und erwachsen.
Wie viele Kinder haben Sie?
Zwei.
Sind Sie gesund?
Die sind, ja so viel ich weiß, meine die haben nichts, ja.
Okay, was waren Sie vom Beruf?
Ich war Automechaniker.
Ja, und so in der Werkstatt, da ist es halt ja auch nicht gemütlich,
da ist es kalt und zugig und man wird dreckig und ja,
das ist für die Gelenke nicht gut, deswegen, also ich denke,
da habe ich mir schon so die Arthrose geholt, ja.
Ja, verstanden.
Letzte Frage, Herr Lüders, waren Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland?
Ja, das ist schon über ein Jahr her, da war ich mal in Österreich,
aber sonst gar nicht.
Wann war das?
Über ein Jahr her.
Okay, ich bin jetzt fertig mit meinen Fragen, Herr Lüders.
Möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ja, was kann das denn sein und ich habe natürlich so ein bisschen Sorge,
weil mein Vater halt diesen Darmkrebs hatte, ob das irgendwie so was sein könnte.
Und ja, jetzt, ja, gegen die Schmerzen,
das wäre schon auch gut, wenn das mal jetzt irgendwann aufhören würde, ne.
Ja, ich verstehe Ihre Sorgen ganz gut, aber machen Sie sich keine Sorgen.
Momentan kann ich Ihnen vielleicht nicht genauer sagen,
was Sie haben, wir haben nur unser Anamnese-Gespräch fertiggestellt,
aber nach bisherigen Angaben habe ich einen Verdacht
auf eine Magendarm-Schleimhaut- Entzündung.
Aber zur weiteren Abklärung müssen wir noch weitere Untersuchungen durchführen.
Ich werde sie zuerst körperlich untersuchen,
besonders untersuche ich ihren Bauch und werde ich von Ihnen
Blut abnehmen, um einige Laborwerte zu überprüfen.
Danach werde ich bei Ihnen Ultraschall von Ihrem Bauch durchführen
und gegebenenfalls CT von Ihrem Bauch,
Computer-Tomographie von Ihrem Bauch veranlassen.
Nachdem alle Befunde und Ergebnisse vorliegen,
erst dann können wir über Ihre Diagnose und zwei weitere Maßnahmen,
notwendige Maßnahmen, sprechen.
Okay, gut.
Vielen Dank.
Hat jemand noch Fragen?
Herr Lüders, eine Frage stellen.
Wenn Sie Schmerzmittel bekommen, nehmen Sie Magen-Säureheme
oder nicht?
Auch nüchtern Magen oder voller Magen nehmen Sie diese Schmerzmittel?
Ja, kommt drauf an.
Wenn ich nachts nicht schlafen kann,
dann habe ich Abendbrot gegessen oder so.
Wenn das über Tag ist, dann habe ich ja auch meistens
ein bisschen was gegessen.
Danke.
Herr Lüders, haben Sie in der letzten Zeit Magen-Spielung oder Darm-Spiegelung?
Nein, nein.
Es ist noch nie gemacht worden, glaube ich.
Noch weitere Fragen?
Herr Kollege, nehmen Sie seit?
Er war ja haarscharf in der Zeit.
Die letzte Frage kam auf den Gong.
Dann kamen nur noch meine Fragen.
Das war ja wirklich ein astreines Anamnesegespräch.
Ich bin gespannt auf das Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch.
Aber machen Sie Ihren Ruhes.
Sie sagen Bescheid, wenn Sie fertig sind.
Ich brauche ein paar Minuten.
Alles gut.
Hallo, guten Tag.
Omer Demir ist mein Name.
Ich bin hier als Assistenzarzt tätig.
Ich habe heute einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Ich würde gerne Ihren Fall vorstellen, wenn Sie kurz Zeit hätten.
Ja, natürlich.
Es handelt sich um Herrn Peter Lüders.
Er ist 69 Jahre alt, geboren am 23. März 1957.
Er ist 1,79 Meter groß und wiegt zurzeit 74 Kilo.
Der 69-jährige Patient, Herr Lüders, stelle sich heute bei uns.
Wegen seit zwei Wochen bestehender, langsam aufgetretener Schmerzen im Oberbau,
im periomaligen Bereich vor.
Er beschreibt die Schmerzen druckend.
Die Schmerzen würden nicht ausstrahlen.
Er berichtete über Nausee und zweimaliges Emesis.
Das Erbrochene sei unauffällig gewesen, nur Essensreste.
Er klagte über Dyspepsie, das allgemeine Krankheitsgefühl.
Seit einigen Monaten sind erweckte Stuhlgewohnheiten zwischen Diarrhea und Obstipation.
Darüber hinaus gab er an, dass er heute Morgen Melena gemerkt habe.
Die Frage nach Fibers, Tachikardien, Dyspneus, Hautverfarbung wurden verneint.
Diese Beschwerden würden sich bei der Nahrung von Haferbrei, Banane und Tee verbessern,
während sich durch Fleischessen verschlechtern würde.
Die Schmerzintensität liegt auf der NRS 4 bis 5,10.
Die vegetative Anamnese ergab Nuklears 2x Corona, symptombedingte Inapetens,
Gewichtabnahme von 6 Monaten von 10 Kilo und durch Schlafstörungen.
Als Vorerkrankung hatte er seit 15 Jahren Diabetes mellitus type 2.
Seit 5 Jahren hatte er Arteriellehypertonie.
Seit 10 Jahren leidet er an beiden Seiten, Gonarthros und Coxarthros.
Als Medikamenten nimmt er mit 800 mg Morgens ein.
Seine Blutstücke Spiegel sind gut eingestellt.
Er nimmt bei Bedarf Ibuprofen 600 mg ein.
Er hat früher eine Medikamenten-Genome gegen Arteriellehypertonie genommen.
Aber das ist jetzt weggefallen.
Er nimmt seitdem keine Medikamenten gegen Arteriellehypertonie.
Als Kind wurde eine Tonsillektomie durchgeführt.
Die OP ist komplikationslos verlaufen.
Bei ihm ist eine Novalgenallergie und eine Jodalergie bekannt.
Die Jodalergie ist durch Atemnot, Dyspne und Exanthem.
Er raucht seit 10 Jahren täglich 10 Zigaretten.
Früher hat er für 30 Jahre eine Packung Zigaretten geraucht.
Er trinkt täglich zwei Flaschen Bier.
Früher hat er regelmäßig neben Bier Schnaps getrunken.
Drogen wurden verneint.
Sein Vater ist an einem Kolonkarsenom gestorben.
Seine Mutter ist wegen Suizid verstorben.
Er ist ein Zellkinder.
Er ist verheiratet und hat zwei gesunde Kinder.
Er ist Rentner.
Er ist Rentner und hat zuvor als Mechatroniker gearbeitet.
Auto-Mechaniker.
Ich kann meine Schreiben nicht lesen.
Zu der Zeit gab es noch keine Mechatroniker.
Ich habe einen Verdacht auf eine Gastritis.
Die Diagnose muss mit der Kronik in Betracht gezogen werden.
Was machen Sie diagnostisch mit dem Patienten?
Ich werde ihn in der Störstkörperung untersuchen.
Besonders fokussiere ich mich auf die Bauchuntersuchung.
Ich inspektiere den Bauch.
Ich werde seine Vitalparameter überprüfen.
Ich werde eine EKG schreiben.
Ich werde Blut abnehmen.
Ich werde die Laborwerte überprüfen.
Ich werde die Blutbild- entzündungsparameter überprüfen.
Leber- und Nierenwerte, Troponinwerte,
Gerinnungsparameter, Alkalenphosphatas und andere Pankreaswerte.
Bilirubinwerte.
Außerdem werde ich die Stuhluntersuchung veranlassen.
Als Bildgebend werde ich die Sonographie vom Bauch veranlassen.
Was erwarten Sie?
Was erwarte ich von einer Sonographie?
Ich werde eine Flüssigkeit ansammeln.
Oder wenn es ein akutes Abdomen vorliegt,
Eiteransammlung.
Danach werde ich die Gastroskopie durchführen.
Ich werde die Stuhluntersuchung vom Abdomen veranlassen.
Mit Kontrastmittel veranlassen.
Worauf müssen Sie achten?
Bei der Stuhluntersuchung?
Ja, mit Kontrastmittel.
Wenn ich eine andere Stuhluntersuchung habe,
veranlasse ich eine andere Kontrastmittel oder ohne Kontrastmittel.
Was können Sie mit dem Abdomen CT ausschließen?
Mit dem Abdomen CT können wir die Perforation ausschließen.
Wenn Sie von einer Ihrer Differentialdiagnosen ausgehen?
Nein, nicht Kularn.
Magenkarsenom kann ich ausschließen.
Und auch eine Metastasierung?
Ja, genau.
Ich bin gespannt, was bei Ihren Untersuchungen rauskommt.
Halten Sie mich bitte auf dem Laufenden.
Dann schauen wir, was wir mit den Patienten machen.
Vielen Dank.
Wenn Sie Ihre Ergebnisse haben, schauen wir uns den Patienten an.
Es bleibt nichts zu wünschen übrig.
Sie haben eine schöne Anamnese gemacht.
Prachlich wirklich super.
Fast einwandfrei.
Eine winzige Sache.
Zwei ganz winzige Sachen.
Sie haben gesagt, wenn er Bauchschmerzen hat,
dann isst er besonders leichte Speisen.
Haferbrei oder Tee mit Zwieback oder eine Banane.
Das würde es verbessern.
Wenn er Fleisch isst, würde das verschlechtert.
Das hat er aber nicht gesagt.
Er mag kein Fleisch essen.
Das ist etwas anderes.
Sie haben einen süßen Sprachfehler gemacht.
Ich inspiziere.
Die Inspektion.
Wie soll ich das sagen?
Inspiziere.
Das ist das einzige.
Sie sprechen ausgezeichnet Deutsch.
Minimal machen Sie ein bisschen L.
Das machen wir alle.
Sie sind absolut sicher in der Grammatik.
Ihnen fehlen auch keine Vokabeln.
Sie können wirklich sehr gut die Fachterminologie
in das Arzt-Arts-Gespräch einbringen.
Ihre Gliederung von der Schilderung war perfekt.
Solche Anamnesen können wir immer gerne haben.
Sie brauchen keine Sorgen vor Ihren Brüsten.
Wenn Sie mit der Inspektion
durchmarschieren,
kann kein Prüfer etwas finden.
Ich bin überzäunt.
Mit der Zeit habe ich ein bisschen Probleme.
Mit der Zeit bleibt keine Zeit.
Sie waren eigentlich in der Zeit.
Die letzte Frage ging mit dem Gong.
Aber sprachlich richtig gut.
Gut.